Let's continue our discussion about Donald
Trump and voting and vote by mail.
Republicans are not even pretending to hide
their desire to suppress turnout in November.
Why?
Republicans know lower turnout is better for
them.
It's it.
You know, sometimes we have to get into the
weeds and explain this, that they just know
it's better for them, for fewer people to
vote.
Donald Trump also, by the way, vote by mail
creates a paper trail, which they don't want.
It makes it more difficult to disenfranchise
people.
They don't want any of this stuff.
Right.
Donald Trump has been ranting and raving against
vote by mail for more than a month, not month.
Now, in the last week, we've seen this full
court press from him and from his press secretary
and from others.
Donald Trump threatening to withhold money
from states if they do vote by mail, is already
told you.
Michigan and Nevada.
And now Donald Trump used this word honor
again when talking about suppressing votes.
You might remember earlier this week, Donald
Trump said it was an honor to have the most
corona virus cases in the world.
That was really weird.
Here is video of Trump again arguing against
vote by mail, saying voting is an honor.
Now, in reality, voting is a right.
But let's take a listen to what Trump said.
Common sense would tell you that it's massive
manipulation can take place, massive day.
And you do you have cases of fraudulent ballots
where they actually print them and they give
them to people to sign.
Maybe the same person signs them with different
writing, different pens.
I don't know.
Is a lot of things going to happen now if
you can?
You should go and vote.
Voting is an honor.
It shouldn't be something where they send
you a pile of stuff and you send it back.
Voting is an honor.
It shouldn't be something where they send
you a pile of stuff.
Donald Trump says they send you a ballot,
the same ballot you would get at the ballot
box and they send you an envelope in which
you return that ballot.
It's not a pile of stuff.
Now, what's fascinating is that what Trump
is describing is, is, number one, a terrible
way to win an election.
And number two, it's something that it's exclusively
Republicans who have been caught doing it.
So there's the retail.
Whoa, sorry.
I hit my mike there.
There's the retail strategy of voter fraud.
And then there's the wholesale strategy of
voter suppression and election fraud.
So the retail strategy is what Trump is talking
about.
You know, vote by mail is a way that people
could send in two ballots or, you know, you
vote harvesting or whatever the case may be.
Terrible way to win elections.
And it also doesn't happen.
Seven to eight instances of vote by mail fraud
per year.
Statistically, zero.
The wholesale strategy is you suppress the
vote, you buy election officials, you reduce
turnout.
That is actually the simpler and more effective
way of stealing elections.
So the entire strategy Trump is describing
here, you know, duplicates and printing ballots
and all of this different stuff, it doesn't
happen.
It doesn't happen.
250 million absentee ballots have been cast
over the last 20 years and we have seven to
eight instances of so-called fraud with those
per year.
Trump again, though, talking about fake ballots
and the like.
Take a look.
That's happening in Michigan.
Well, I think if we're talking about the mail
in ballots, if people mail in ballots is a
lot of illegality.
They send in ballots that they harvest ballots,
you know, all about harvesting and they do
lots of bad things.
Ideally, people go out and they vote.
Now, if you need a mail in ballot, if you
need a specific like as an example, I'm in
the White House and I have to send the ballot
to Florida.
That makes sense.
So if you need it for some reason or if somebody
is not.
Well, that's one thing.
But when you send out 7.7 million mail in
ballots this fall.
Injuries there is frankly, duplication where
they print ballots on the same kinds of paper
with the same kind of machinery and you can't
tell the difference and they send in thousands
and thousands of fake ballots.
And I tell you what, the station can't be
gone down that path because it's a very dangerous
path to go down.
This is not a dangerous path to go down.
It's a very advanced and sophisticated path
to go down ballot harvesting, which Trump
talks about.
That's something Republicans have been caught
doing.
And other than a couple of instances of Republicans
doing it.
We don't know of any ballot harvesting that
turned any election.
I believe there was a special election.
I think there was one district in 2018.
I don't remember if it was a special I think
was North Carolina.
I wish I had it in front of me where this
sort of funny business from a Republican strategist
likely influence the results or it could have.
There are really no other examples of it now.
On the other hand, the strategies that the
right uses, like voter suppression, closing
down voting places, put purging people from
voter rolls.
That is how you actually suppress the vote
in order to win elections.
You know, double votes, in-person voter fraud,
absentee ballot fraud doesn't win you elections.
Now, let's talk about the bigger picture just
a little bit.
Not much good is likely to come from Corona
virus.
We can hope, right?
We can hope this will be a wake up call, will
realize how fragile our economic systems are,
and we will strengthen them.
We will make them antifragile.
To take a phrase from Naseem.
Naseem late Nicholas Taleb.
We might realize that we were totally unprepared
for a pandemic will get better prepared for
the next pandemic.
I don't know that that's really going to happen.
Trump disbanded the pandemic response team
from shouldn't have.
We didn't shut things down quickly enough
for March 5th would have been a perfectly
reasonable time to do.
It didn't happen.
South Korea did it.
Taiwan did it.
New Zealand did it.
There's a lot to learn.
I don't know that we're going to learn anything
there if we can move a bunch of states to
vote by mail.
It would be a major advancement and maybe
we can make some progress there.
But this entire voting is an honor thing.
Don't be tricked.
Voting is a right period.
This entire voting is an honor and it should
be done the way Trump likes.
It's publicly justifying voter suppression
specifically to get Donald Trump reelected.
Trump sees the polls.
Trump publicly says Joe Biden has no shot,
but we know Trump is scared.
Trump two weeks ago furiously got on the phone
with his campaign manager, Brad Paşa scale
and said, how the hell am I losing to Joe
Biden?
Michigan could be key for Donald Trump.
He's threatening Michigan about vote by mail.
They are doing it in broad daylight.
They have to be stopped in.
One of the ways that we stop them is by ensuring
that every body votes
in November.